si quisiera saber qué fracción de esta
tabla está pintada en este color rosa
haremos lo siguiente primero vamos a
preguntarnos cuántos espacios del mismo
tamaño tenemos en esta tabla y esta
tabla tiene 1 2 3 4 5 renglones por 123
columnas sería un total de 15 cuadros
iguales vamos a hacer una cosa vamos a
contarlos para saber que estamos en lo
correcto 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 tenemos 15 rectángulos totales en
esta tabla de estos 15 rectángulos
totales que son todos del mismo tamaño
cuántos de ellos están pintados en rosa
y contemos tenemos 12
456 tenemos 6
tenemos seis pintados en rosa de los
quince totales y para poder representar
estos seis quince años existen también
las fracciones equivalentes y en este
caso tengo algún presentimiento que hay
alguna forma más pequeña de poder
representarlo para hacer eso vamos a
volver a dibujar nuestra tabla y la
llevaremos aquí
tenemos ahora nuestra tabla y vamos a
volver a dibujar los seis cuadros que
están pintados en rosa solo que esta vez
los dibujaremos digamos por bloque de
una manera mucho más pegadita y
empecemos tenemos uno lo voy a dibujar
lo más rápido que pueda
vamos a la mitad
estamos cubriendo es exactamente el
mismo espacio tenemos el área de 615 a
vos tanto arriba como abajo vamos a
escribirlo tenemos 6 rectángulos de los
15 rectángulos totales que tenemos en
esta tabla ahora cómo podemos hacer esto
una una fracción equivalente
simplificada lo que haremos es darnos
cuenta que tanto el numerador como el
denominador tienen factores comunes y en
este caso el más grande que puedo ver es
el 3 porque tanto el numerador como el
denominador son divisibles entre 3 si yo
divido el numerador entre 3
y también divido el denominador entre 3
no estaré afectando el valor de la
fracción y si podré simplificar lo de
esta manera tendremos 6 entre 3 es igual
a 2
15 entre 3 es igual a 5
y cómo es que estos dos quintos tienen
sentido en ser exactamente lo mismo que
615 a vos vamos a verlo si nosotros
hablamos de tener bloques de tres como
lo tenemos aquí estaríamos marcando que
este es uno de los bloques
casi no se ve vamos a ponerlo
más grueso
y aquí ya se ve
este sería un primer bloque
y aquí tendríamos otro segundo bloque
es más voy a dibujarlo por dentro para
que se vea mejor
que estoy dibujando
esto es un poco más para que se vea cómo
quedaron los bloques de tres y así
tenemos dos bloques
aquí se ven ya los dos bloques en
amarillo 1 2 y la pregunta sería cuántos
bloques de este mismo tamaño tengo pues
está muy fácil porque tengo 1 2 3 4 5 5
bloques es más voy también a quitar aquí
estos espacios para que se vea
perfectamente cuáles son los bloques de
los que estoy hablando
tenemos exactamente el área que estaba
cubriendo 615 a vos pero ahora no
tenemos como 200 y tiene sentido porque
ahora tenemos estos dos bloques
amarillos de 5 totales
que tenemos del mismo tamaño por eso
podemos decir que 615 abós es
equivalente a dos quintos o si nos
preguntamos cuál será la fracción
simplificada de 615 abós tendremos dos
quintos y ahora saben por qué